I said late last week that I believe the democratic
primary racist down to two candidates.
Those candidates are Bernard Sanders and Joseph
Biden.
The numbers show you that.
We now have Joe Biden polling 28.7 and an
average of recent polls.
Bernie right there pulling 24.3 and an average
of recent polls far back in third place is
Elizabeth Warren at 15.
So I don't really think anybody else has a
shot at the nomination here.
I don't think Buddha judge has a shot at the
nomination.
I don't believe Andrew Yang has a shot.
I don't think Klobuchar has a shot.
I don't think tool C has a shot.
I don't think Stire has a shot.
And I don't really think Michael Bloomberg
has a shot either.
But I actually can put together a path to
the nomination for Bloomberg that I simply
can't for the other people that I listed.
So let's talk about Michael Bloomberg a little
bit here.
Um, Bloomberg has accelerated to fourth place.
Okay.
He entered this race very late.
He spent an insane, ungodly amount of money
to buy his way into fourth place, averaging
almost 8% now.
Okay.
Pete boot edge edge has been campaigning.
Who the hell knows how long at this point?
And he's going nowhere.
He's just been stuck.
And Michael Bloomberg has almost caught up
to Pete, Buddha judge already.
And I see a path for Michael Bloomberg.
Now I want to be clear.
I know there will people who are furious.
They're going to misunderstand me.
I'm not supporting Michael Bloomberg.
I'm not voting for Michael Bloomberg and the
primary.
I don't think that Michael Bloomberg winning
the primary is likely, but I've identified
a path where I do think Bloomberg's shot is
being underestimated by the polling that we
see and I think that he will end up doing
better than a lot of people predict.
This is merely because he's pouring money
in like that's all this is.
He's just buying his way in and he's being
strategic about where he pours that money
in the way that the polls are going.
Between Bernie and Biden, Bernie Sanders may
well win a number of those early primary States
that'll deflate Joe Biden's campaign.
Let's take a look at some of the polling.
When we look at Iowa now, Bernie has taken
the lead quite decisively.
When we look at New Hampshire, the second
state to vote, Bernie is also a head there.
Biden fight, fight Biden is fighting more
for second place with Pete than for first
place.
Then you will have in Nevada, either a split
between Bernie and Biden or one or the other.
We'll win a little bit, but it'll be close.
So they'll get a similar, similar number of
delegates.
And then the fourth primary in South Carolina
will almost certainly go to Biden by a bigger
margin.
Biden's been way ahead in South Carolina for
awhile.
So imagine that after the first four primaries,
we have a graphic up on the screen with the
first four primaries, the number of delegates
in each state.
Remember, as long as you get 15%, you get
a share of the delegates based on current
polling.
So if Bernie wins, uh, if Bernie wins the
first three, uh, or the first two, and it's
sort of a split in Nevada and then Biden wins.
In any case, if you look at an average of
recent polling, you could have some Bernie
wins with a bigger win by Biden and South
Carolina.
And you could end up with, for example, 39
delegates to Biden and 31 to Bernie or something
close to that.
Now after each primary, Bloomberg will concentrate
his spending more and more on the March 3rd
super Tuesday States.
The idea, of course, getting to the 15% threshold
in some key States, including California,
that looks tough.
Bloomberg's only pulling six in California,
but there's a bunch of States on super Tuesday
and if Bloomberg, based on how effective it's
been to spread his money around so far, if
Bloomberg concentrates on other hundred million
or who knows how much, 200 million, 300 million
in those super Tuesday States, we can get
to super Tuesday and Bloomberg pulls a bunch
of delegates.
He could be an actually a reasonable third
place position if he keeps climbing in the
polls merely at the rate he's been climbing
so far.
If Biden and Bernie keep trading off, if Biden
looks increasingly tired and slow, you could
see a case made by the establishment on March
4th that Bloomberg seems as viable as Biden.
Bloomberg has more momentum than Biden and
Bloomberg has way more cash than Biden.
You could see the establishment get behind
Michael Bloomberg and then it's anybody's
questioned what happens next.
Now, all the caveats, I'm not rooting for
this scenario.
I don't believe this is the most likely scenario.
I don't believe this is a good scenario for
the country.
This is just that I think Michael Bloomberg
is more viable than those who say any day.
Now yang will, we'll start winning all the
primaries or people who say, Buddha judge,
who has been even for four months any day
now he's going to come and take leads and
win some primaries or tool.
See any second you'll see she'll win Iowa,
New Hampshire, and then it's off to the races.
No, Bloomberg has been steadily rising in
proportion to the amount of money that he
pours in.
If he concentrates the money in super Tuesday
States, he could come out of super Tuesday
with some delegates, some momentum, and possibly
move the establishment behind him and away
from Biden again meant to deny Bernie Sanders
the nomination.
Let me know.
We think it's a possible path.
Not saying it's likely, it's possible.
It's more likely that Bloomberg is the nominee
than Buddha, judge or yang or toolset are
the nominees.
Let me put it that way.